Ukraine have you heard about this we got
a situation brewing they have officially
seceded in Crimea from the Ukraine they
voted they're joining Russia 97% just
shy of the hundred percent that Kim
jong-un got in his reelection bid in
North Korea pretty good right there was
an interesting op-ed in USA Today by ron
paul not Rand Paul he's hot these days
but it was by ron paul about what the US
is role in Ukraine should be what's the
big deal opponents of the Crimea vote
like to point out to the illegality of
the referendum but self-determination is
a centerpiece of international law
article 1 of the United Nations Charter
points out clearly that the purpose of
the UN is to develop friendly relations
among nations based on respect for the
principle of equal rights and
self-determination of peoples perhaps
the US officials who supported the
unconstitutional overthrow of Ukraine's
government should refocus their energies
on learning our own constitution which
does not allow the US government to
overthrow governments overseas or send a
billion dollars to bail out Ukraine and
its international creditors okay so I
thought this was interesting because
you're not going to hear anything about
Rand Paul's feelings on this in the news
but I think he does some up sort of the
way a lot of people feel like what the
hell does this have to do with us that's
sort of how I feel how do you guys feel
what what should our role in this place
that's halfway across the world be yeah
I don't know I mean I sort of disagree
with ron paul in this which is i think
this is a big issue in the world focus
should be on this right now i think this
is a really important moment
geopolitically when the borders are
shifting and we should be paying
attention and i think if it wasn't for
so much focus on the malaysian playing i
do think we would be paying attention so
I mean that's my take on it and you know
Ron Paul and I sort of disagree about a
lot of things we're the 25 hour a day
coverage of the plane is a bit too much
is that what you're saying no i mean i
run into the plane coverage but i also
just think that this is a this is an
important moment it's important moment
for the united states is important
moment for europe and it's important
moment for for the Ukraine certainly in
Russia all right so we'll talk about why
it's important but first do you put it
in that category somewhere no I
definitely agree i mean forget the fact
that ron paul is the guy old men on his
lawn yelling about the thing in the
paper he saw this morning than helpful
as well he's doing it but I mean you
can't ignore the fact that a country was
just taken back by another country
because they saw a hole in the gate like
it's literally like the guy next door is
Putin and he hears you and your wife
arguing and he goes well here's my
chance to go take this guy's life
because they're there they're fighting
so I could get in there and like quietly
it that's it that's serious too like you
can just take another country like what
year is this right so so what should our
role be though because I'm with you guys
that yet he should not be doing this and
obviously the ninety seven percent that
voted for it obviously that's [ __ ]
but what should we do where we can arm
you I mean John McCain saying we should
arm Ukraine like he was another angry
that's big of an angry old man will top
you're angry oh man oh you be angry man
will just get your gun every no matter
what the situation is get your gun but
don't do you think that Rob what Ron
Paul saying that does sort of resonate
with a lot of people in the United
States right now just this idea that we
just shouldn't be all over the place
whatever it is we're only gonna make it
worse I think that's sort of a yeah I
mean I I mean that's a valid point I
think too but you know Ron Paul is also
is you know has argued on the other side
of that fence a lot of times where there
should be sort of intervention and
certainly John McCain who argues for
intervention all the time I mean this is
it's an opportunity that the world
should be just focusing on attention and
paying attention to the situation are
you for intervention and cupcake wars
break your Venture this right yeah um
but don't so don't you see this as sort
of that Putin just feels like he can do
whatever he wants using your analogy so
so what and I think you can't uh you
can't be America and not do anything
because you're America and everyone's
like you're the supposed to be known who
helps us when we another country the
need like what are we supposed to do
like American help us and so when you do
nothing of almost week and he is
unresponsive and then when he does
something it's not the right thing so as
a as the world superpower we have to I
mean it's because the bush Iraq thing
kind of burned out our tolerance for
intervention anywhere and so we as a
country have to reel
put that behind us we have to focus on
what's happening now and we have to deal
with problems that arise in the world
that could affect us in the future no
matter what happened in the past and if
that means intervening in another
countries whatever it may be we have to
examine that I also worry that you know
this isn't this is maybe the first
opportunity where Putin is sort of
putting back together the Soviet Union
and so we just have to pay attention to
that I think both from you know
political standpoint and also from human
rights standpoint which this could cause
a refugee crisis I mean this could be a
serious and I'm by no means a hawk but
this is a moment where I think like you
know let's let's keep an eye on and see
what happens is the scary part of this
whole thing that maybe Sarah Palin and
Mitt Romney were actually right about
something is that is that absolutely the
scariest totally a broken clock is Right
twice a kind of thing it just so
happened to ya really fall in their lap
and I mean if you look at the look at
the opening ceremonies it was really
Putin pining for the USSR like really
like this is what he wanted and he's
trying to get the band back together
yeah is the other problem here that this
is sort of unmasked once again i think
that the UN is just sort of pointless
when it comes to doing pretty much
anything because we veto things on the
Security Council we don't like Russia
now invades another country vetoes
things that they don't like so really it
is just up to us because we're the last
super so we don't do anything we sort of
we're damned if we do damned if we don't
cuz there's nobody else but you an is
good at blocking traffic in New York
when they had got the people in town
that's got one thing that really good so
that one week when they have the General
Assembly they're really really good
really going to shut down the city
decide yeah is there any point in the UN
at this point I still have a lot of love
for the UN despite the fact that they
brought cholera to Haiti which was a
personal issue in vendetta that I had
against the UN but I still think there
is a place for a world body that can try
to speak with a unified voice and a
little bit of reason here and there I
think they've been ineffective a lot
there's probably needs to be a lot of
reform but it would be a scary world I
think that didn't have a United Nation
indefinitely
you